some of the planets in our solar system
are gigantic but what if they got even
bigger
let's go up the planetary size chart and
see what kind of chaos doubling the size
of every planet would make
what would it be like to live on a super
earth
how big would jupiter need to get to
become a star
and would pluto finally regain its
planetary status
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all the planets doubled in
size
doubling the radius of every planet in
the solar system
would make each of them eight times more
massive but
you wouldn't need to worry about our
solar system's great ball of fire
getting bigger and hotter
for the sake of this experiment let's
keep the sun the same size it already is
but could the gravitational pull of a
super jupiter kick start a chain of
events that would result in the
destruction of the solar system
well before we go further down that
chain let's thank our sponsor
established titles you know everyone
knows me as the lord of what if or at
least they will soon established titles
gives people all over the world the
chance to partake in the scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
lords lairds or ladies yeah you can buy
one square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston scotland
which allows you to become a lord or a
lady and established titles plants one
tree for every order as a way to
preserve not just the biodiversity of
scotland but forest creation efforts
worldwide use the link in the
description below and the first 200
people who purchase a title pack will
have a plot next to mine we can have our
own what-if kingdom while supporting a
great cause and right now established
titles is running a big labor day sale
so use the code what if to get an
additional 10 off your order go to
establishtitles.com
what if to get your gifts now
lord peter
it's got a nice ring to it
mercury
at its current size the rocky planet
closest to the sun is only slightly
larger than our moon
doubling it in size would make it nearly
half as massive as earth
and despite the fact that mercury
stopped being volcanically active three
and a half billion years ago expanding
its interior would mean all that
internal energy would need to escape
somewhere
so there could be some more explosive
volcanic eruptions in mercury's future
venus
venus is very similar in size to earth
but one of its many differences is that
its atmosphere is so thick that the
surface pressure is 95 times stronger
than our own
venus's increased gravity would pull the
atmosphere even closer to its surface
this could result in the atmosphere
becoming so dense that walking through
it would feel more like walking through
water
except you'd really be walking through
incredibly thick carbon dioxide
earth
[Music]
if earth expanded to twice its size
the first big change you'd notice is
that you'd feel a lot heavier
within seconds you'd go from your 75
kilogram weight to feeling like you were
150 kilograms
that would be because the force of
gravity pulling on you would be twice as
strong
you better hit the gym to strengthen up
fast because
this wouldn't be easy on your body
your heart would need to work twice as
hard to pump blood around and pressure
would build up on your joints
jumping flying or sending rockets into
space could become a thing of the past
you'd need much more fuel power and
money to leave earth's surface and
travel through its even thicker
atmosphere
mars
now if the red planet ballooned to twice
its size
there's a chance you would barely
recognize it
what was once a dry desolate place could
eventually transform into a more
earth-like planet with oceans rivers and
a thick atmosphere
mars lost its magnetic field and then
its atmosphere likely because of
chemical changes inside its core
but if the martian core got bigger and
hotter it could restart the magnetic
field and that in turn would protect
mars from solar winds and give it a
chance at kickstarting life
jupiter
doubled in size jupiter would continue
to be an intimidatingly huge planet
it would stay
318 times larger than earth and two and
a half times more massive than all the
other planets combined
and the impact of this would be so huge
that it would likely shift the actual
center of our solar system
you see the planets in our solar system
don't exactly revolve around the sun
no they orbit the common center of mass
or berry center
and thanks to jupiter's normal size this
berry center is actually 48 000
kilometers away from the center of the
sun
but doubled up this point in space would
move even further away from the sun
you'd see material from the asteroid
belt being pulled toward jupiter or
further out into the solar system but
even this big jupiter wouldn't be
massive enough to become a full-blown
star
to do that it would need to increase to
85 times its current mass
though it wouldn't be far off from star
status
at 13 times its original mass jupiter
could become a brown dwarf star
saturn
with a bigger saturn
you could kiss its beautiful rings
goodbye the monumental increase in the
planet's surface gravity would upset the
balance of the ring materials as well as
saturn's five small moons
they'd start falling towards its surface
at a higher rate
saturn is already slowly losing its
rings
every 30 minutes material containing
enough water to fill an olympic-sized
swimming pool falls down to the planet
uranus
now beyond its added heft
not all that much would change for the
ice giant uranus way out on the edges of
the solar system
it would continue holding the record for
the stinkiest planet
if doubling uranus's size would mean
doubling the amount of hydrogen sulfide
in its upper atmosphere
this stinker might spread an even
stronger stench of rotten eggs
well
i wouldn't want to go near this planet
neptune
neptune's fate wouldn't be too different
from its giant frozen neighbor
except neptune's increased gravitational
pull
could eventually lead to the
disappearance of some or all of the
billions of icy objects located outside
its orbit
neptune has already swallowed the
equivalent of 7 to 10 times the mass of
earth in material from the kuiper belt
pluto
if pluto doubled in size well it could
be back on track to regain its official
status as a planet
if its added mass and gravity could
manage to pull away debris from its
surrounding neighborhood
it might just be able to rejoin the rest
of the family
all right so it's safe to say that all
the planets doubling in size
wouldn't exactly bring about a
cataclysmic end of the solar system it
would however cause a little chaos
but not nearly as much as if the sun
became big enough to swallow earth
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]